Okay, the next value algorithm we're going to look at
is what is called the Tournament Barrier. The barrier
is organized in the form of the tournament with
N players and since it's a tournament with N players
and two players playing as, against each other. In
every match there are going to be log N rounds, log
N with a base 2. So here is the
setup for with [INAUDIBLE], they're going to be, they're going to be,
three rounds corresponding to login. And being
eight we get three rounds. The first round,
second round and the third round. So in
the first round, they're going to be four matches.
P0 and P1 is one match. P2, P3. P4, P5. P6,
P7. And the only catch is that we're going to rig this
tournament. In other words what's going to happen is that we're
going to predetermine who is going to be the winner in
this round. And, and particularly, we're going to say P0
is the winner for this match, P2 for this
one, P4 for this one, and P6 for this one.
So in other words, the matches are rigged. In
this day and age, when we hear about international scandals
about match fixing. I guess this is not too
far fetched. But what is the rational for match fixing?
The key rational is the fact, that if the
processes are executing on a shared memory machine. Then
the winner can basically sit on his bumper and
wait for a process of P1 to come over
and let him know that he has won the match, P2 can wait until P3 comes over and
so on and so forth. And what that means
in a shared memory multiprocessor, is that the spin
location where P0 is waiting for P1 to
come and inform him that he's lost the match
is fixed. The static. And, and so this is
the idea behind match fixing, that the, the spin
location for each of these processes, P0, P2,
and P4, and P6, the winners in the first
round, is predetermined. And that is very, very useful,
especially if you don't have a cache coherent multiprocessor.
If you have NCC [UNKNOWN] machine, In that
case it is possible to locate the spin location,
in the memory that is very to P0 P2 P4 and P si, P 6 respectively. That's
the idea behind this this match fixing. So
the result of matches. Of course P0 will advance
to the next round. P2 will advance to
the, next round. P4 and P6. And once again,
in the second drawing we're going to fix the matches. And the winner is going to
be P0 for round 2. P4 for in this bracket for round 2. And so
essentially what that means again, is that P0 and P4 can spin on a
statically determined location. In various processors
and P2 and P6 respectively will come over and let
the other guy know that when the match [UNKNOWN] for this
round. So that is the end of the second round. And, and,
and, of course, if you have you know, with N equal
to eight, there are only three rounds but, if, for arbitrary N,
we're going to have more levels in the tree and the and
the, and, and, and [INAUDIBLE] level. We're going to fix the the winners
and, so it'll propagate up this tree in this fashion, in
terms of determining statically, who are going to be the winners for
each round of the tournament. And this will go
on, all the way up to determining who the
tournament champion is. So in this case, P0 is
our luck guy, who wins the tournament and so he's
the champion. And so P0's going to be waiting on
a statically determined location, where P4 can come and signal
that P0 has one determinant. So again, the important
thing that I want you to get out of this
this particular arrangement that I've mentioned is the fact that the
spin location for each of the processors that are waiting on the
other guy are statically determined. At every level. So this the
first round, the second round, and
finally the championship, the championship round.